bien le bonjour à toutes et à tous comme
l'avait annoncé le président de la
république je reviens devant vous quinze
jours après la mise en place du
confinement pour faire un point sur la
situation sanitaire sur les mesures que
nous déployons pour lutter contre
l'épidémie et sur les perspectives qui
nous attendent dans les prochaines
semaines quel bilan pouvons nous faire
aujourd'hui de la situation la france
vous le savez affronte une deuxième
vague épidémique extrêmement forte qui
touche tout aussi gourmands l'ensemble
de nos voisins européens comme l'avions
annoncé l'impact sanitaire de l'épidémie
reste très lourd
le nombre de décès continue d'augmenter
au cours des deux derniers mois nous
avons connu plus de dix mille décès
supplémentaires dus à la colline 19
portant le nombre total de personnes
décédées à quarante deux mille cinq cent
depuis le début de la pandémie au cours
de la dernière semaine entre 400 et 500
personnes sont mortes chaque jour d'un
que vous cela veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
en france
un décès sur quatre est due au virus
au-delà de ces chiffres il s'agit de
femmes et d'hommes il s'agit de vies
brisées par la maladie il s'agit de la
douleur de milliers de familles
auxquelles je veux dire ma solidarité et
dans l'émotion dans l'épreuve deuxième
élément de constats sur la situation
sanitaire
la pression sur notre système
hospitalier s'est fortement accrue aînés
nos soignants dans une tension extrême
la viande anticiper tout l'enjeu
et d'y faire face avec une seule
exigence pouvoir soigner toutes celles
et ceux qui en ont besoin et éviter à
tout prix
le drame de prise en charge dégradée
comme nous pouvons l'observer par
exemple en italie depuis quelques jours
nous comptons ces derniers jours une
hospitalisation toutes les 30 secondes
et une admission en réanimation toutes
les 3 minutes 40 % 40 % des personnes
admises en réanimation ont moins de 65
ans c'est évidemment considérable et
nous avons dépassé en nombre
d'hospitalisations le pic du mahdavi
aujourd'hui ce sont 4 1803 malades de
lakovic qui sont pris en charge en
réanimation ce qui représente 95% de nos
capacités normales de lits de
réanimation au requise pour pouvoir
faire face à cet afflux
nous avons armée au cours des deux
dernières semaines
mille trois cent soixante lits
supplémentaires afin d'accueillir plus
de malades
braquo vie mais aussi d'autres malades
qui doivent être prises en charge pour
d'autres motifs
nous pourrions aller jusqu'à dix mille
400 livres si cela était nécessaire
puisque nous nous sommes préparés au
cours des derniers mois pour faire face
à une vague de grande ampleur
je veux venir ici une nouvelle fois
toute mon admiration à nos
professionnels de santé ils sont à
l'épreuve
ils sont fatigués mais je les observe
très directement au fil de mes
déplacements réguliers dans nos
établissements de santé ils sont
remarquables de compétences d'engagement
et de solidarité
tout le monde est sur le pont
les établissements publics les
établissements privés les professionnels
libéraux
les personnels de l'ensemble des
administrations sanitaires
ces soignants ils ne nous demandent pas
d'augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation
ne serait ce que parce qu'ils savent
bien que formé un médecin réanimateur ou
une infirmière spécialisée ne peut pas
se faire en six mois ils nous demandent
surtout de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
éviter que les malades arrivent à
l'hôpital
quel bilan pouvons nous faire de la mise
en oeuvre des mesures de confinement
depuis le 30 octobre vous le savez nous
n'avons pas souhaité reproduire le
confinement du printemps dernier qui
s'était traduit par une mise à l'arrêt
brutal de la vie économique sociale et
éducative de notre pays les effets que
nous pouvons mesurer sont à ce jour
qu'on ira avec ce que nous recherchions
un confinement adapté qui cherchent à
limiter au maximum tous les déplacements
non essentiels mais qui préserve
l'éducation de nos enfants et l'inique
autant que possible ses impacts sur
l'emploi et sur l'économie
quelques chiffres nous observons une
réduction très forte des déplacements
depuis deux semaines les déplacements
entre le domicile et le travail sont
inférieures de 22% à ce qu'ils étaient
en septembre des amis la fréquentation
des moyens de transport collectif a
fortement baissé moins 55% dans le métro
à paris par exemple
c'est aussi le cas des déplacements
longue distance puisque le réseau aérien
de
les sticks et à 10 % de ses capacités
norman tandis que les déplacements en
train longue distance ont chuté de 85%
ces chiffres s'expliquent par la
limitation de nos déplacements non
professionnels mais aussi par un recours
accru au télétravail qui a fortement
progressé au cours des deux dernières
semaines
45 % des salariés privés ont télétravail
et au cours de la semaine écoulée pour
une durée moyenne de 3 7 jours dans la
semaine mais nous pouvons encore
progresser
la ministre et isabelle borne y revient
ce recours on a cru au télétravail
accompagne une stratégie de confinement
qui place la sécurité sanitaire au
premier plan tout en essayant de
préserver l'activité économique et donc
l'emploi
de ce point de vue les dernières données
de la banque de france montrent que
l'activité économique pourrait baisser
de 12% au mois de novembre
c'est un choc important mais c'est trois
fois moins qu'au printemps dernier
quel est l'impact de ce confinement sur
les vidéos
nous constatons que l'évolution du
nombre de nouvelles contaminations s'est
ralenti depuis une seule si l'on
raisonne en moyenne sur 7 jours nous
observons une baisse de l'ordre de 16%
cette évolution doit être interprétée de
manière positive mais prudente positive
car elle traduit une inflexion et c'est
ce que nous espérions positive car cette
tendance si elle se confirme indiquerait
que ce qu'on appelle taux de
reproduction du virus le fameux air est
passé en dessous de 1 pour se situer
entre 0,8 et 0,9 mais prudente car cette
tendance récente donc fragile
et ne peut produire des résultats que si
elle se confirme dans la durée prudence
enfin car nous ne voyons pas encore
l'impact de cette évolution sur les
hospitalisations alors que cette
fondamentalement notre objectif
l'enseignement que je tire de ces
différents éléments et que notre
stratégie de confinement fondé sur un
équilibre différent en mars dernier
semble produire les premiers effets
attendus même si nous devons rester je
voulais dit très prudente nous pouvons
tirer de cela trois autres conclusions
la première est il serait irresponsable
de lever ou même d'alléger le dispositif
dès maintenant nous avons dans un cadre
concerté avec la communauté éducative
adapter les règles dans les lycées afin
d'y accroître le respecte de la sécurité
sanitaire
le ministre chargé de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer rire
viendra avec le président de la
république
nous avons donc décidé ce matin de
maintenir inchangés au moins pour les 15
prochains jours
les règles du confinement les commerces
fermés au titre du confinement le
resteront donc encore pour 15 jours
supplémentaires
je sais ce qu'est l'angoissé commerçants
qui n'aspire qu'à pouvoir travailler et
sont très inquiets de ne pouvoir rouvrir
à ses taux avant les fêtes de fin
d'année notre objectif est bien de
pouvoir y parvenir
mais ce moment n'est pas encore venu
cette décision je la prends en
responsabilité elle est lourde et
difficile mais mon rôle n'est pas
aujourd'hui dans le sens de la facilité
de céder à la pression de faire ce qui
serait espérée par beaucoup et je les
comprends
au risque de tout compromettre et de
nous
j'ai à refermer dans deux semaines et
peut-être pour tout le mois de décembre
le deuxième enseignement que je tire est
que nous devons évidemment continuer à
apporter un soutien économique massif à
tous les commerces et toutes les
entreprises qui ont été contraintes de
fermer
j'assume mes responsabilités en termes
de protection contre l'épidémie
j'entends les assumer de la même manière
pour protéger les victimes économiques
du confinement pour les entreprises et
commerces fermés les dispositifs dette
que nous mettons en place seront
rappelées dans un instant par le
ministre bruno le maire
ils se traduiront par le versement des
premières aides financières au titre de
l'activité partielle du fonds de
solidarité de 10000 euros par mois dans
les prochains jours et d'ici la fin du
mois de novembre
à partir d'exemples très concrets le
ministre vous montrera d'un pack très
puissant de nos différentes aides pour
couvrir les pertes de chiffre d'affaires
nous avons un objectif tout faire pour
sauver nos petits commerces
notre soutient nous le devons aussi aux
salariés
d'abord en prolongeant les dispositifs
de chômage partiel qui ont permis depuis
le printemps de sauver les emplois et de
préserver le pouvoir d'achat
pour ceux qui ont perdu leur emploi au
cours des derniers mois et notamment
pour les demandeurs d'emploi qui
arrivent en fin de droits tout doit être
fait pour éviter le risque de basculer
dans la précarité
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à la
ministre du travail de proposer aux
partenaires sociaux qu'elle réunissait
cet après-midi de rependu le dispositif
de prolongation exceptionnelle des
droits à l'assurance chômage pour les
chômeurs
qui sont aujourd'hui en fin de droits
est ce le temps du confit nous sommes
particulièrement attentifs à la
situation d'isolement des plus jeunes de
nos concitoyens et en particulier des
étudiants dans les établissements nantes
n'assurent plus leur enseignement
sauf exception camp distant ciel dans
les prochains jours sur proposition de
la ministre en charge des universités
chacune des huit cents cité
universitaire de france va disposer de
deux référents étudiants qui viendront
renforcer le travail des services des
crous notamment pour accompagner les
étudiants de première année et les
étudiants les plus en difficulté ce sont
1 2600 emplois étudiants qui seront
ainsi créés sur les mois de novembre
décembre et janvier
dans un contexte où l'emploi étudiant
s'est par ailleurs raréfient plus
généralement nous veillons déploiement
du plan un jeune une solution qui
mobilise vous le savez une part
importante des crédits du plan de
relance plan de relance plus que jamais
nécessaire pour contrecarrer les effets
nocifs de la crise sanitaire sur la
situation de l'emploi
la troisième et dernière le sens qu'il
est nécessaire de tirer de ce premier
bilan à 15 jours et que l'enjeu des
jours qui viennent est surtout de ne pas
relâcher nos efforts mais de les
amplifier
je remercie très sincèrement l'immense
majorité des françaises et des français
qui respecte les règles communes mais
nous constatons dans certaines zones
partie du territoire de respect encore
insuffisant de ses rêves après une
première phase ii nécessaire pédagogie
j'ai donné au ministre de l'intérieur
des consignes de fermeté et lui ai
demandé d'accroître encore la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre
notamment à paris annie de france et
dans l'est
en métropole depuis le 30 octobre
les forces de police et de gendarmerie
ont procédé à près de 580 1000 contrôles
qui ont donné lieu à 88 4 155
verbalisation dont environ 300 concerne
l'ouverture régulière d'établissements
recevant du public
au delà des contrôles j'en appelle au
civisme par le respect de ces règles
vous le savez uniquement destiné à
protéger notre santé nous devons rester
constant et cohérent
c'est ce qui nous amène à ne pas faire
évoluer les mesures aujourd'hui je crois
que chacune et chacun le comprend pour
autant si nous ne modifions pas les
choses aujourd'hui il est important que
nous puissions donner de la visibilité
sur ce qui pourrait se passer au cours
des prochaines semaines et la manière
dont nous allons suivre les indicateurs
pour en tirer les conséquences sur
l'adaptation de nos mesures d'ici la fin
de l'année
nous suivons principalement deux
indicateurs l'indicateur de circulation
du virus
c'est un nombre de cas par jour qu'une
telle que l'an sur la moyenne des sept
derniers jours
pour lisser les fluctuations d'un jour
sur l'autre un indicateur de pression
sur le système hospitalier
c'est le nombre de patients kovy
hospitalisés en réanimation
comme je voulais indiqué nous observons
depuis une semaine un infléchissement du
nombre de cas positifs
non seulement il a arrêté d'augmenter
mais la courbe marque une tendance à la
baisse l'ours de 16% sur la dernière
semaine
si la semaine prochaine cette tendance
se confirmait pas et que le nombre de
patients qu'aux vie dans l'animation
devait continuer à augmenter alors nous
serions amenés à prendre des mesures
supplémentaires afin d'arrêter là bas si
au contraire quand vous laisse sur la
tendance observée ces derniers jours se
confiant nous pensons que le pic de la
deuxième vague pourrait être atteint
dans nos hôpitaux
en début de semaine prochaine comme vous
le voyez sur le graphique qui s'affiche
cela signifie qu'à partir de la semaine
prochaine le nombre de patients que
vides en réanimation pourrait nous
l'espérons commencé à diminuer ce serait
une très bonne nouvelle
une première étape très importante mais
qui ne suffira évidemment pas pour que
la pression sur le système hospitalier
reviennent à des niveaux supportables
si l'augmentation des chiffres des
prochaines semaines confirmait que nous
restons bien en ligne avec ses
perspectives des premières mesures
d'allégement pourrait intervenir à
compter du 1er décembre mais elle serait
strictement limitée au commerce que nous
avons dû fermer à partir du confinement
et leur réouverture ne pourrait
s'envisager que sur la base d'un
protocole renforcé que j'ai demandé aux
ministres compétents de concerter avec
les professionnels et de soumettre aux
instances scientifiques
cette première étape ne pourra cependant
pas concerner d'autres établissements
recevant du public où les risques de
contamination sont par nature plus élevé
comme par exemple les bars les
restaurants et les salles de sport
bien entendu pour ces établissements des
mesures de soutien et d'accompagnement
seront maintenus notre objectif est de
pouvoir permettre un nouvel allègement
au moment des vacances de noël afin que
les français puissent passer des fêtes
de fin d'année entraînements mais celles
ci ne pourront pas se tenir de la même
manière qu'eux
d'habitude on pourra bien sûr se
retrouver avec les siens mais il ne
serait pas raisonnable d'espérer pouvoir
organiser de grandes fêtes à plusieurs
dizaines de personnes notamment pour le
réveillon du 31 décembre
je vais maintenant demander à olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités de la
santé de vous présenter un point sur la
situation hospitalière et sur
l'évolution de notre stratégie de
dépistage par les tests dits anti g
monsieur oui monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames messieurs comme le
premier ministre vient de l'expliquer on
voit depuis une semaine une réduction du
nombre de nouveaux diagnostics quotidien
par rapport aux semaines précédentes et
comme le premier ministre l'a aussi très
bien expliqué
pour autant comme il ya un décalage
entre le moment où les contaminations
sont faits et le moment où les patients
présentent des formes graves ayant
recours donc à l'hôpital au service de
réanimation comme il ya ce décalage nous
ne sommes pas encore une phase de
réduction du nombre d'hospitalisations
et d'admission en réanimation
donc il n'ya pas de paradoxe à cela
c'est le constat que nous avions fait
déjà au printemps dernier à l'occasion
de la première vague ainsi de fait la
pression sanitaires continuent
d'augmenter sur la médecine de ville sur
les services d'urgence sur les hôpitaux
et sur les réanimations puisque
davantage le patient qui rentre à
l'hôpital est en réanimation qui est de
patients qui en sortent nous ne sommes
pas donc encore au pic
mais comme le premier ministre l'a dit
nous pourrions atteindre le pic
hospitalier dans les prochains jours en
tout cas nous nous l'espérons pour
pouvoir faire face à cette pression
sanitaires extrêmement forte notamment
sur le secteur hospitalier
nous poursuivons le développement le
déploiement la préparation des hôpitaux
avec la mobilisation encore une fois
incroyable
de l'ensemble des soignants sur tout le
territoire national il ya ce soir plus
de 7700 lit de réuni de réanimation ar
mais puisque comme vous savez en plus
des presque 5000 patients coded en
réanimation il y à des malades qui sont
barrées service de réa ou d'autres
maladies suite à des interventions
chirurgicales des infarctus et rupture
d'anévrisme et autres rien que pour la
région auvergne rhône-alpes qui vous le
savez la région la plus impactée à
l'heure actuelle par l'épidémie c'est
quasiment x 2 en termes de lits de
réanimation dépassé de 6 en ligne dorée
armé dans cette région a presque 1210 a
remis tout cela ne se fait pas d'un
claquement de doigts et nécessite de
gros efforts au quotidien
le premier effort à réaliser c'est ce
qu'on appelle la déprogrammation des
soins de chirurgie non urgents tout en
pérennisant sanctuary en quelque sorte
la chirurgie encore sérologie l'activité
de greffe ainsi que d'autres chirurgies
absolument indispensable mais donc de
fait un certain nombre de malades qui
devait être opéré sont rappelées dans
différentes régions du territoire pour
leur demander de différer leur
intervention chirurgicale pour garder de
la place disponible pour les malades
atteints bucovine c'est également la
mobilisation sans précédent de
l'ensemble des soignants mais aussi des
étudiants sont internés des externes et
internes en médecine les soignants
retraités sur tout le territoire et puis
de ces soignants qui se sont formés au
cours de ces derniers mois aux
techniques de réanimation et qui vont
prêter main forte à leurs collègues dans
les services hospitaliers et c'est enfin
ce qu'on appelle les évacuations
sanitaires vous souvenez de ces
évacuations sanitaires qui avaient été
réalisés déjà au printemps dernier c'est
lorsqu'on transfert un patient d'un
service de réanimation d'une région vers
un autre service dans une autre région
par avion par hélicoptère tout cela
nécessite aussi un énorme travail et
mobilise beaucoup de personnel ce sont
plus de 120 évacuation
r qui ont déjà été réalisées les régions
les plus en tension comme aux vers
grenade ou bourgogne franche comté vers
d'autres territoires comme la nouvelle
aquitaine bretagne ou encore l'île de
france je le disais c'est une logistique
lourde c'est aussi un déplacement pour
les malades qui se retrouvent donc
éloignèrent de leurs proches c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé de prendre en
charge les frais de transport et
d'hébergement pour au moins un
accompagnant des patients lorsqu'ils
sont transférés dans le cadre de ces
évacuations sanitaires
par ailleurs nous l'avons déjà dit et
notamment la semaine dernière nous avons
appris davantage sur comment bien
prendre en charge des malades atteints
du coded et nous avons fait d'énormes
progrès en matière de connaissances et
d'organisation et de logistique
notamment à l'hôpital mais pas que
souvenez vous la semaine dernière nous
avons présenté avec des médecins
généralistes comment la prise en charge
s'organiser désormais davantage médecine
de ville au domicile du patient
les sociétés savantes les collège des
médecins les soignants ont été
massivement consulter les
recommandations ont été arrêtés qui vont
permettre à chaque professionnel de
santé qu'il soit en ville ou à l'hôpital
de disposer de la bonne manière de
soigner et d'accompagner les patients
ça peut aller d'ailleurs jusqu'à
l'équipement en oxygène au domicile des
malades lorsqu'ils ont une forme
symptomatique mais dont l'état de santé
ne justifie pas une hospitalisation
de la même manière nous avons développé
vous le savez la téléexpertise télésanté
la télémédecine qui permet d'accompagner
les patients à leur domicile mais
également les soldes ans les infirmières
à domicile qui s'occupe de surveiller
leurs malades dans leur maison nous
avons également fait ce qu'on appelle
une villa tation de tout le secteur
hospitalier c'est-à-dire que nous avons
amélioré encore les prises en charge
dans les
vis de soins critiques dans les services
de soins intensifs de soins continus qui
sont capables d'accueillir désormais
dans leur lit des malades qui autrefois
aller systématiquement en réanimation
n'ont pas le malin qui sont placés en
coma et qui sont qui ont un tube dans
les bronches pour les aider à respirer
mais des malades dont l'état est
instable mais qui je dirais se satisfait
d'une oxygénation c'est-à-dire de
l'arrivée d'oxygène à très fort débit
par voie nasale tout cela nous permet de
vraiment d'augmenter de façon massive
l'ensemble des capacités de prise en
charge et accueille des malades dans les
hôpitaux ce qui fait que si nous avons
déjà presque atteint le nombre
d'hospitalisations de la première vague
et bien nous sommes à un niveau
d'admission en réanimation à ce stade et
nous l'espérons au de bons intérieurs au
nombre de dossiers utilisation en
réanimation qu observer pendant la
première vague et puis par ailleurs nous
avons également réduit les durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation à l'hôpital quand en
réanimation notamment en nous appuyant
sur les services de rééducation ou sur
les sorties d'hôpital précoce vers le
domicile où là aussi les patients
peuvent être traités par anti coagulant
corticoïdes et oxygène suivis par leur
médecin traitant et par des infirmiers
libéraux
ce qui permet de diminuer la part de
l'hôpital m'a prise en charge et de
réduire un peu d'impact de la question
sanitaire sur nos établissements
deuxième volet que vous m'avez demandé
l'amendé monsieur le premier ministre
sur la question des tests antigénique
d'abord rappeler qu'en france nous
réalisons toujours environ deux millions
deux cent mille tests pcr par semaine ce
qui fait que la france reste le pays
d'europe qui testent le plus avec
l'angleterre est avec l'allemagne nous
avons cette innovation formidable que
sont les tests en dziennik je rappelle
un écouvillon nage naso pharyngé comme
pour un test pcr classiques et ensuite
au lieu d'envoyer le prélèvement dans un
laboratoire et bien la personne qui
réalise ce prélèvement le directement
par une petite manip technique regardez
sur un test si vous êtes positif
pour le virus donc si vous ne l'êtes pas
si vous êtes patients symptomatiques et
si vous voulez être positif au test même
si vous étiez d'ailleurs asymptomatiques
si votre test est positif
la fiabilité du test est excellente elle
est un petit peu moins en revanche
lorsque le test est négatif
et si vous êtes symptomatique et que
votre test antigénique lui négatif il
est possible qu'on vous demande de faire
quand même à fès le pcr pour compléter
les expérimentations grandeur nature ont
été menées dans tout le pays depuis
plusieurs semaines rien qu'un exemple la
semaine dernière sur la semaine qui
s'est écoulée
cent soixante mille têtes antigénique
ont été faites auprès de soignants dans
les ehpad de tout notre pays
ces tests antigénique se déploie aussi
massivement dans les services d'urgences
à l'hôpital quand il faut savoir si un
patient qui a de la fièvre
il faut savoir très rapidement si c'est
le cas au vide ou non il se déploie
également dans les aéroports dans les
ports et bientôt dans les prochains
jours à partir de la semaine prochaine
ils vont se déployer également dans les
établissements scolaires à destination
du personnel enseignant mais n'en sont
d'ailleurs du personnel qui peut
travailler dans les écoles de manière à
permettre de lever toute suspicion de
maladie lorsque quelqu'un peut centrer
par exemple des symptômes alors vous si
vous êtes dans la situation de vous
poser la question si vous pouvez
bénéficier d'un test antigénique et bien
c'est très simple si vous êtes
symptomatique
sachez que désormais bon nombre de
pharmaciens d'officine en ville mais
également de médecins libéraux et
d'infirmiers libéraux sont formés et
réalise désormais eux-mêmes des tests
antigénique et donc si vous tombez sur
un professionnel de santé qui a fait ce
choix
eh bien il pourra vous proposer ce
diagnostic par test antigénique rien que
dans la journée d'hier 3000 français ont
été diagnostiqués positifs bien vitesse
antigénique fait auprès de leurs
professionnels de santé en ville et vous
bénéficierez de la même manière du
contact traces
et des mesures de mise à l'abri si vous
êtes évidemment positif si vous êtes
asymptomatiques deux cas de figure si
vous êtes assez symptomatique n'est qu'à
contacter les recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé qui vient dans
un très gros travail sont que vous devez
bénéficier d'un test classique en
laboratoire par pcr et si pareil
par contre vous êtes asymptomatiques
mais pas qu'à contacter eh bien
peut-être que vous pourrez être dépistés
par test antigénique chez votre
professionnel de santé je dis peut-être
parce qu'il n'en a pas l'obligation mais
si il a de la place disponible et killer
que nos choix il pourra vous faire
bénéficier de ce test
par ailleurs un certain nombre de
collectivités mais également
d'entreprises nous ont fait savoir
qu'elles souhaitaient procéder à des
campagnes de dépistage
à partir de ces tests antigénique dans
les prochains jours nous serons amenés à
présenter des protocoles qui permettront
d'accompagner les collectivités et les
entreprises dans la réalisation de ces
dépistages par tout ça fait sens
évidemment sous la responsabilité d'un
professionnel de santé
nous avons de question d'y revenir la
semaine prochaine enfin sachez que nous
l'état français a passé une commande
supplémentaire de près de 20 millions de
tests antigénique dans le cadre d'un
appel d'autres européens ce qui permet
de compléter notre disponibles sachant
que par ailleurs les pharmaciens les
médecins peuvent acheter eux-mêmes des
tests auprès des différents laboratoires
agréés
donc voyez cette technique de test se
développe elle ne remplacera pas les
tests pcr qui sont fiables qui sont
efficaces et qui mobilise toute la
filière de biologie dans le pays elle va
venir
implémenter compléter enrichir partout
où c'est nécessaire
notre capacité de dépistage merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre nous
allons faire un point sur la situation
dans l'éducation nationale et je demande
à monsieur le ministre jean michel
blanquer de bien vouloir procéder
merci monsieur le premier ministre pour
la peau l'éducation nationale la crise
de la gestion de la crise connue depuis
l'apparition en mars et la consignation
de deux exigences
l'exigence d'abord d'arriver à ce qu'il
y ait une continuité des apprentissages
et puis l'exigence évidemment de
protection center
c'est cette exigence qui a commandé
l'ensemble des mesures prises depuis le
mois de mars et je suis d'ailleurs
l'occasion en début de semaine indiquées
l'impact des politiques que nous avons
pu mener sur les élèves notamment à
l'école primaire je voudrais rappeler
très brièvement parce que nous perdons
pas de vue nos priorités dans cette
période à l'école primaire c'est lire
écrire compter spt au tri à la sortie
des écoles primaires ce que nous voyons
c'est que les élèves de cp l'an dernier
ont un peu pâti de la période de de
confinement nous avons pu atténuer
certains les inconvénients mais
néanmoins ils sont bâtis de ce
confinement
les élèves de cm2 pour prendre les deux
classes aux extrémités de l'école
élémentaire ont continué les progrès de
constater qu'on constate l année
précédente on le voit il ne faut pas
perdre de vue cet enjeu qui est majeure
et si je regarde les résultats de la
france sur cette question nous
réussissons à traverser l'épidémie en
assurant la continuité des
apprentissages
bien sûr ça reste l'enjeu depuis cette
rentrée et cela reste l'enjeu sur le
plan sanitaire dans le cadre du
protocole sanitaire qui a été définie au
mois de juillet il prévoit vous savez
différentes mesures en fonction des
situations épidémiologiques possible
donc nous avons un cadre de mesures dans
lesquels pour lesquels pourront faire
évoluer les curseurs et c'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis le 1er septembre le
protocole s'est appliqué du 1er
septembre au 16 octobre et nous a permis
le retour en classe de pratiquement tous
les élèves à l'école au collège et au
lycée
mais insiste encore sur ce point c'est
une victoire une victoire d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des professeurs et les
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
des collectivités locales puisque tous
les pays n'ont pas pu faire ça et
aujourd'hui ce retour à l'école
enfants reste un objectif fondamental la
deuxième vague qui a d'ailleurs été
accentuée s'agissant des enfants et des
adolescents par les vacances d'automne
nous a conduits à faire plein au curseur
et c'est donc la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes depuis maintenant une
semaine et demie nous avons en d'autres
termes durs si le protocole ses
nouvelles à la mesure applicable depuis
le 2 novembre consistent surtout à la
limitation des brassages les brassages
des élèves
la généralisation du port du masque pour
tous les élèves et le cp en sachant que
tous les personnels le portait depuis la
rentrée mais aussi l'aération la
désinfection plus fréquente des locaux
autant de mesures qui d'ailleurs souvent
sont prises avec les collectivités
locales dont c'est la compétence
s'agissant des bâtiments nous avons
laissé aux écoles et aux établissements
quelques jours pour s'adapter retour des
vacances scolaires et certains
établissements en plus de difficultés
que d'autres parce que chaque école
chaque collège chaque lycée est un cas
différent
rappelons qu'il ya plus de soixante
mille établissements scolaires et écoles
en france dans les lycées la limitation
du brassage des élèves les plus
complexes à organiser d'une part du fait
de la taille des établissements et d'une
part et d'autre part du fait des
déplacements plus nombreux des élèves
la structure du groupe classe et
beaucoup moins établi qu'en primaire au
collège et en plus l'âge des élèves et
leur mode de vie rendent cette
population des lèvres plus sensibles aux
risques sanitaires
c'est pourquoi nous avons prévu depuis
la semaine dernière une souplesse pour
l'essai de façon à ce que dans un cadre
national bien défini ils puissent avoir
des adaptations locales correspondant à
leur réalité nous avons établi cela en
lien notamment avec les chefs
d'établissements les partenaires sociaux
et ce cadrage précise que dans la mesure
où un lycée peut encore le faire c'est
le cas par exemple
deux lycées où il ya peu d'élèves et
bien sûr la présence à 100 % des élèves
reste souhaité mais dès lors qu'il n'est
pas possible pour un établissement
d'assurer les conditions sanitaires
requises autres tous les élèves sont
présents et bien les solutions hybrides
sont proposés j'ai toutefois demandé que
au minimum 50% du temps scolaire de
l'élève se déroule dans le lycée d'ici à
la fin de l'année civile afin de
garantir le maintien d'un lien fort avec
la classe j'ai demandé aussi à ce que
chaque lycées et à vis avec le soutien
de suivi de chaque rectorat d'un plan
précis de continuité pédagogique qui
détaille les modalités d enseignement et
notamment de l'enseignement à distance
pour l'élève avec les collectivités
locales
nous avons travaillé tout au long des
derniers mois aux signes avant
l'acquisition de matériel informatique
que pour l'équipement des établissements
eux mêmes
et puis il ya eu des sessions de
formation des professeurs toutes ces
actions continuent encore aujourd'hui au
cours des prochaines semaines
les académies les rectorats donc ont mis
en place des cellules de continuité
pédagogique pour accompagner et suivre
la bonne mise en place de ces plans la
mise en mode de l'enseignement à
distance demande une forte mobilisation
des chefs d'établissement et des
professeurs
je veux remercier tout ceux qui
contribuent aujourd'hui à cette
continuité pédagogique
nous allons par ailleurs des déployé
plus de jeunes du service civique plus
d'assistants d'éducation et plus de
professeurs remplaçants dans le premier
degré comme dans le second degré chaque
fois que cela sera nécessaire voudrais
enfin faire référence à la politique de
tests dont le ministre olivier ferrand
vient de
nous parler parce que en effet dans le
cadre du travail accompli entre le
ministère de la santé et le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
il y aura plus de dépistage des
personnels travaillant dans nos écoles
et dans nos établissements scolaires
dans les prochaines heures une
instruction interministérielle sera
envoyé à toutes les académies et à
toutes les agences régionales de santé
et rappelle que nos personnels sont
prioritaires dont l'accès aux tests pcr
elle permet aussi le déploiement de près
d'un million deux cent mille postes
antigénique qui seront mis à disposition
des établissements scolaires avec des
personnels de santé venus les
administrations de santé comme de
l'éducation nationale
certaines zones plus exposés au virus
seront prioritaires et l'instruction
précise toutes les modalités de
déploiement de ses fesses voudrais à
nouveau remercier tous nos personnels
mais aussi les parents d'élèves pour la
période difficile que nous traversons
notre critère c'est toujours les lèvres
lui permettre d'aller à l'école d'aller
au collège et d'aller au temps possible
au lycée de bénéficier d'une continuité
pédagogique de continuer à accomplir nos
deux objectifs fondamentaux qui sont
hausser le niveau général du pays et
d'assurer la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales
or nous savons qu'elles peuvent être
aggravées par un confinement des aides
nous pouvons avoir à la fois de la
cohérence et de la cohésion dans
l'ensemble des mesures qui sont prises
merci donc à tous ceux qui y contribuent
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup aux limitations fonctionnelles
pour évoquer la mise en place du
confinement dans les milieux
professionnels et notamment la question
du télétravail j'invite madame isabelle
borne ministre en charge du sujet à
s'exprimer devant vous merci monsieur x
ministre
bonsoir à toutes et à tous le premier
ministre l'a rappelé la situation que
nous
bon en ce moment n'est pas la même qu'au
printemps dernier
en mars nous avions demandé aux français
de rester chez eux et de faire ce qu'ils
pouvaient en télétravail il de fait
notre économie s'était largement arrêté
nous voulons cette fois que l'activité
économique se poursuive matière de
télétravail je le rappelle la règle
s'applique désormais est la suivante
ce dont les tâches peuvent être
entièrement réalisés à distance doit
être télétravail et cinq jours sur cinq
ce qui ne peuvent télétravail et que
partiellement qui sont dans
l'impossibilité de le faire peuvent
continuer à se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail ou toute sécurité grâce au
protocole sanitaire
l'entreprise qui garantit leur
protection cela fait maintenant deux
semaines que ces règles sont entrées en
vigueur après une première semaine test
pour laisser le temps aux employeurs et
aux salariés de s'organiser nous avons
mené une enquête auprès de 2000 français
du 4 au 8 novembre dernier pour voir si
les règles étaient bien appliquée
l'enquète le montre la très grande
majorité des employeurs et des salariés
jouent le jeu et je les en remercie
première confirmation de cette enquête
tous les français ne peuvent pas
télétravail et un tiers des actifs peu
télétravail est facilement mais plus
d'un tiers des français dont un métier
qui n'est pas du tout et les
travaillable deuxième enseignement l'
enquête montre qu'une majorité de ceux
qui peuvent télétravail et l'ont fait et
ils ont fait davantage que la semaine
précédente
ainsi 45 % des salariés du privé qui ont
travaillé la semaine dernier
on fait du télétravail dont 23% cinq
jours sur cinq
c'est un bon score quand on sait que
tous les salariés ne peuvent pas t'aider
travailler autre point positif ce qui ce
se qui télétravaillent le font davantage
en moyenne 3 7 jours contre 2,7
la semaine d'avant en ce qui concerne le
télétravail dans le secteur public
il progresse également près de 40% des
agents de l'état hors éducation
nationale police et gendarmerie sont
aujourd'hui en télétravail soit près de
12 points de plus que la semaine
précédente
et n'oublions pas comme l'a rappelé
amélie de montchanin la ministre de la
fonction publique que nous voulons aussi
maintenir les services publics ouverts
contrairement aux premiers confinement
troisième enseignement le télétravail
cinq jours sur 5 représente un véritable
effort pour les salariés qui souffrent
parfois d'isolement en effet près de six
français sur dix qui ont télétravail est
à 100% préféré venir sur leur lieu de
travail ou moins un jour par semaine
quatre salariés sur dix qui ont
télétravail et la semaine dernière dit
se sentir isolé pour leur venir en aide
et accompagne et tous ceux qui ne
bénéficient pas de dispositif de soutien
psychologique dans leur entreprise
nous avons lancé une ligne d'écouté et
de conseil dans numéro s'affiche à
l'écran j'ai conscience que nous
demandons un effort très important aux
employeurs et aux salariés les il est
indispensable dans la lutte contre le
virus
je tiens à les remercier une nouvelle
fois pour leur mobilisation
les enquêtes le montrent il y a encore
des marges de progrès pour que plus
d'actifs télétravail j'appelle donc tous
les employeurs et les salariés à
poursuivre leurs efforts chaque jour
chaque heure télétravail est content
concernant la situation du marché du
travail et des demandeurs d'emploi je le
redis le confinement actuelle n'est pas
le même au printemps dernier
nous avons fait le choix de maintenir
l'activité économique de notre pays et
de nombreux secteurs continuent à
tourner et à voir ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle
une activité soutenue il existe des
opportunités d'emploi malgré la période
on a compté trois cent quarante mille
créations d'emplois au troisième
trimestre 2020 elles seront encore
dynamisée par le plan de relance
le service public de l'emploi continue à
fonctionner avec le maintien de
l'accueil dans les agences de pôle
emploi et les missions locales les
équipes sont mobilisées pour accompagner
les demandeurs d'emploi il y à des
métiers en tension des métiers porteurs
il y à des offres d'emploi non pourvues
il ya aussi des formations pour
permettre demandeurs d'emploi d'aller
vers des solutions durables
notre priorité reste l'emploi nous avons
conscience que la situation est
difficile pour un grand nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi et nous devons plus
que jamais rassurer et protéger comme
l'a annoncé le premier ministre
nous allons donc prolongé de la durée du
confinement les droits à l'assurance
chômage pour les chômeurs arrivant en
fin de droit par exemple un demandeur
d'emploi dont les droits hors aygulf
s'éteindre fin novembre continuera à
toucher son allocation chômage au mois
de décembre
nous laissons également un délai
supplémentaire pour s'inscrire à pôle
emploi
un demandeur d'emploi qui doit réunir
les pièces pour s'inscrire bénéficiera
d'un délai supplémentaire pour
rassembler tous les justificatifs
nécessaires ce qui peut être plus
difficile dans la période de confinement
enfin nous allongeons la période de
référence de bénéficier d'une allocation
chômage alors qu'aujourd'hui un
demandeur d'emploi doit avoir travaillé
travaillé au moins quatre mois sur une
période de 27 mois
ces 27 mois seront prolongés de la durée
du confinement
nous avons entendu les inquiétudes des
demandeurs d'emploi ou plus largement
des partenaires sociaux et des
associations
contre la pauvreté soyez assurés que
nous sommes déterminés à y répondre
je remercie merci beaucoup mal ministre
j'ai évoqué les sujets essentiels de
l'accompagnement économique des secteurs
en difficulté notamment de ceux qui sont
impactés par les mesures de sécurité
sanitaire que nous prenons j'invite
ministre en charge économie des finances
et de la relance bruno le maire à vous
faire un point à ce jour merci monsieur
le premier ministre 1 comme l'indiqué le
premier ministre les commerçants sont au
coeur de nos préoccupations comme des
préoccupations de chacun d'entre nous je
sais que nombre de commerçants on axe de
rouvrir le plus rapidement possible que
beaucoup ont constitué des stocks ont vu
les fêtes de noël et les fêtes de fin
d'année souvent ils doivent payer ses
stocks au moment même où ils sont
fermées et où non pas de trésorerie
disponible
par ailleurs beaucoup d'entre eux je
pense aux libraires je pense aux
bijoutiers magasin de jouets font près
de la moitié de leur chiffre d'affaires
dans les deux derniers mois de l'année
la réouverture est donc vital pour eux
et ils le sentent
je crois que le calendrier que vient de
fixer le premier ministre et de ce point
de vue un motif d'espoir pour les
commerçants français
mais la meilleure façon de réussir cette
ouverture c'est que chacun respecte les
règles sanitaires dans les jours à venir
cela a été rappelé depuis plusieurs
minutes
en attendant je tiens à vous confirmer
que toutes les mesures économiques
massive que nous avons annoncées avec le
premier ministre le président de la
république au début du mois et que nous
avons mises en place pour les
commerçants continueront de s'appliquer
dans les quinze jours qui viennent et je
veux les rappeler pour que chacun voit
bien à quoi il a droit concrètement les
commerçants qui sont fermées
administrativement
tous sans exception ont le droit à une
aide qui peut aller jusqu'à dix mille
euros pour le fonds de solidarité
ils ont droit à l'activité partielle à
l'exonération de charges sociales et au
report du remboursement des prêts
garantis par l'état
nous veillerons bien entendu à la bonne
exécution de ces dispositifs et je
veillerai personnellement avec la
direction générale des finances
publiques à ce que chaque commerçant
fermés puissent déclarer le chiffre
d'affaires qu'il a perdu disent ils tout
début du mois de décembre afin de
pouvoir bénéficier de ses fesses des
fonds de le thunder était dans les
premiers jours du noir ne laissant ainsi
ceux là dessus parce que je vois
beaucoup de commerçants qui me dise où
sont les aides conviennent tel il faut
que le mois de novembre c'est cool mais
ensuite dans les tout premiers jours du
mois de décembre
ils pourront avoir accès à ce fonds de
solidarité dont je rappelle qu'il
accumule cumulables avec les revenus du
retraitement de click and collect qui
peut constituer un appoint financier
pour certains nous savons également que
la question des douaniers
reste la question majeure pour nine
mance majorité de commerce à la demande
du président de la république et du
premier ministre
je vous annonce que nous mettrons en
place un dispositif saint massif est
nouveau pour les loyers des commerces
ce dispositif résulte des consultations
que j'ai eu depuis plusieurs jours avec
l'ensemble des associations et des
fédérations représentatives des
bailleurs et les commerçants en accord
avec toutes ses associés
j'aurai toutes ces fédérations sans
exception nous mettrons en place sans le
budget 2021
un crédit d'impôt de 50% du montant de
loyer abandonné pour tous les bailleurs
qui renonce au loyer du mois de novembre
pour toutes les entreprises qui ont
jusqu'à 250 salariés et qui sont ferme
et j'invite à nouveau par conséquent
tous les bailleurs qui ont signé cet
accord à renoncer à l'employé du mois de
novembre pour tous les commerces jusqu'à
250 salariés qui sont faire un petit
bailleur par exemple qui pour compléter
sa retraite dispose d'un loyer de 600
euros touchera 300 euros de crédit
d'impôt est locataire nuit et du coup
n'aura pas à payer son loyer du mois de
novembre cela l'aidera à passer cette
période difficile a d'ailleurs plus
important qui renonceraient un loyer de
5000 euros touchera un crédit d'impôt de
2500 euros
nous avons voulu aussi traiter les
entreprises plus importantes une
entreprise de taille intermédiaire pas
s'il ya des galeries marchandes des
galeries commerciales qui sont concernés
mais qui sont elles aussi menacées et
nous n'avons voulu laisser personne de
côté
par conséquent pour les entreprises de
250 jusqu'à 5000 salariés
ce dispositif s'appliquera également
mais dans la limite des deux tiers du
montant des loyers
cela signifie qu'un bailleur qui
renoncent voyez par exemple une grande
surface commerciale pour un loyer de
12000 euros mensuels aura un crédit
d'impôt d'un tiers choix de 4000 euros
je tiens sincèrement à remercier
l'ensemble des associations et
fédérations de bailleurs car c'est la
première fois que nous trouverons un
accord collectif sur mesure de cette
importance qui traduit le sens des
responsabilités et l'esprit de
solidarité sans lequel nous ne pourrons
pas participer pleinement à la relance
notre activité économique pour surmonter
la crise actuelle
enfin comme l'a indiqué le premier
ministre devons mettre à profit les
jours qui viennent pour travailler avec
gérant et les event bornes dans deux
directions
la première c'est l'application des
nouvelles règles sanitaires qui
s'appliqueront au moment de la
réouverture des commerces et quand cette
réouverture sera possible nous pouvons
travailler par exemple sur le
renforcement de la jauge ou
éventuellement pour certains commerces
cela serait pertinent sur la possibilité
de prise de rendez vous je souhaite
également c'est la deuxième direction
dans laquelle nous voulons travailler
engager dès maintenant une nouvelle
consultation avec tous les secteurs dans
lesquels le port du masque n'est pas
possible comme la restauration ou les
salles de sport et où donc par
conséquent les difficultés sont encore
plus grande et où ces difficultés
s'inscrivent hélas quand le long terme
je crois que pour ces secteurs aussi
nous devons donner de la visibilité sur
les points de sortie et préparer un
avenir que nous souhaitons meilleur à
tous merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers concitoyens je veux
vous dire combien je ressens les
difficultés du pays je mesure les
souffrances et parfois le désespoir de
beaucoup d'entre vous adopter des
mesures difficiles constitue évidemment
un crève coeur mais il est de ma
responsabilité de le faire mon devoir
est de vous protéger contre le virus
ses ravages contre le terrorisme contre
le chômage
créé par la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement comme moi même sommes
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
sous l'autorité du président la
république nous avons fait le choix
d'accompagner massivement ceux qui
souffrent ceux qui sont fragiles et
vulnérables ceux qui font l'objet les
mesures à nice at il rendu nécessaire
pour lutter contre la propagation de
l'épidémie et nous continuerons d'agir
dans ce sens
le propre de cette crise c'est qu'elle
nous donne à
toutes et à tous le moyen d'être un
acteur de la lutte contre l'épidémie
l'occasion d'exprimer notre solidarité
notre sens des responsabilités car nul
ne peut se croire invincible ou et paris
nous constatons des évolutions positives
premiers effets des mesures prises ces
évolutions ne justifierait pas un
durcissement des mesures mais elles sont
trop fragiles est trop récente pour
autoriser le moindre relâchement
plus que jamais je vous invite à
respecter rigoureusement les règles du
confinement à ne sortir de chez vous que
lorsque c'est strictement nécessaire est
autorisé à télétravailler au maximum à
redoubler de prudence si vous êtes
particulièrement vulnérables au virus a
observé les gestes barrière le port du
masque y compris chez vous à aérer ou
ventilés au maximum les espaces cloud à
télécharger l'application tous antico
vie je n'ignore rien des polémiques et
des contestations mais ne nous y
trompons pas l'ennemi ce n'est pas
l'état mis le gouvernement c'est le
virus le seul combat qui m'obsède
c'est celui de notre sécurité la seule
cour qui m'intéresse c'est celle des
malades admis à l'hôpital ou en
réanimation
grâce à nos efforts collectifs grâce aux
perspectives ouvre l'arrivée de vaccins
je suis sûr que nous surmonterons cette
épreuve douloureuse et inédite grâce à
notre mobilisation immédiate
j'espère que nous pourrons passer des
fêtes de fin d'année dans la sérénité
je me tiens avec léniniste à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
monsieur le premier ministre
bonsoir madame messieurs les ministres
denis collin pour tf1 et lci
pour bien comprendre vos propos le coup
fumant va-t-il se poursuivre après le
1er décembre et jusqu'aux vacances de
noël avec le même système d'attestation
de dérogation est question
complémentaire pourquoi ne pas obliger à
ne pas envisager progressivement un
passage un confinement territorialisée
des mesures plus dures dans les régions
les plus touchées comme celle de
dauvergne euros nahd et moins durs plus
haut que dans d'autres régions
merci bien autre question bonjour d'hier
et kurt et france 2 vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre de réouverture à partir
du 1er décembre
cela concernera quel commerce qu'elle
vous dis qu'est ce que nous pourrons
faire nos vacances nos courses de noël
dans toutes les boutiques et les tuiles
deuxième question est ce qu'on peut
commencer à prendre nos billets de train
pour les vacances et pour les fêtes de
noël
on va peut-être prendre une troisième
question et après on fait comme
d'habitude je réponds avec des ministres
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre lee
vial delmas le courrier du parlement
vous aviez annoncé précédemment que les
jauges pour les obsèques était de 25
personnes et pour les mariages de six
personnes
sans polémiquer on aurait attendu des
chiffres inverse
je voulais savoir simplement 6
les mails les mêmes mots temps si je
puis dire était heureux continuer de la
même façon pour les obsèques et pour les
mariages bien alors je commence ma
première que s'ils voulaient bien donc
le 1er décembre
j'ai indiqué que compte tenu des
éléments dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
les règles applicables confinement
continuerait à s'appliquer c'est à dire
celles que vous avez dit est que si les
données sanitaires continuent à évoluer
dans le sens de ce que nous observons
aujourd'hui avec la même dynamique
nous pourrions ouvrir alors plein de
commerce se situe à la deuxième question
est bien aujourd'hui sont le sont
couverts que les commerces dits de
première nécessité ou les rayons
correspondants dans les grandes surfaces
ce serait le reste des commerces qui
seraient concernées
j'insiste auprès de vous faut-il que les
données sanitaires le permettre et
faut-il aussi selon l'aide des ministres
que les protocoles qui sont en cours de
discussions de concertations avec les
professionnels concernés aboutissent
dans de bonnes conditions
il m'a été demandé si on pourrait passer
à un confinement plus territorialisée
sous le contrôle du ministre de la santé
je pense que les chances du 1er décembre
qui s'est elle était la question
le moment ne sera pas vraisemblablement
encore venu d'envisager cet état
s'agissant des billets de train je veux
qu'ils aient pardonnez moi et je vais
très bien avec vous un peu tôt pour
répondre à cette question nous nous
sommes le gouvernement s'est renseigné
complet
sncf pour savoir à partir de quand
serait trop tard en sens inverse donc
nous avons encore un peu de temps devant
nous mais très vite en fonction là aussi
des données sanitaires nous pourrons
apporter une réponse claire c'est
qu'elle sorte pour que les français
évidemment puisque je sens bien que tel
était l'objet de votre demande puisse
s'organiser dans des délais raisonnables
pour procéder à ces réservations et je
ne vois pas madame le motif à ce stade
pour modifier par plus d'ailleurs ces
règles que d'autres rues sur les sujets
que vous avez évoqué ma première
question porte sur les conditions de la
réouverture des commerces et se faire
partir du 1er décembre pourquoi vouloir
mettre en place un protocole renforcé en
quelque sorte ne pas garder le protocole
qui existait au moment des gourmands
petits commerces
mon autre question porte sur la prise en
charge des patients pauline vous pariez
du transfert de patients d'une région à
l'autre mais pourquoi ne pas décider de
mettre en place des structures mobiles
ou des hôpitaux de campagne dans les
autres qui sont les plus touchés par mon
dieu merci
les maraudes eu l'effet je me permet de
reposer la question d'un concert de tf1
que nicolas est ce que au 1er décembre
si la tendance actuelle se confirmait
avec les présidents positif il faudra
une attestation pour circuler oui oui
oui
alexis publié de bellaing téléconférence
le premier ministre sur la question des
déplacements après le 1er décembre
est-ce que même si le confinement est
maintenu dans des règles assez strictes
il y aura des possibilités d'aller voir
sa famille et ses proches dans d'autres
régions ou de prendre le train pour
s'éloigner de son milieu de vie et je
pense notamment bien sûr moment des
fêtes de fin d'année une autre question
sur l'objectif de 5000 cas par jour qui
avait été évoquée par le président de la
république au moment son allocution
annonçant leur confinement est ce que
cet objectif vous semble atteignable à
moyen terme et en font une question peut
être un peu plus politique beaucoup de
critiques ces derniers jours dans
l'opposition sur le fonctionnement du
conseil de défense vous les avez
probablement entendu certains
parlementaires notamment ou chefs de
l'opposition de reproche de ne pas être
assez associés à la prise de décision et
dénonce une forme d'opacité
je voudrais avant votre réponse merci
beaucoup avec lui dernière question je
ma part je le droit
bonjour monsieur premier jean nido
d'europe 1 le 6 mai dernier devant le
sénat lors de votre audition en tant que
coordinateur du des confirmands vous
avez déclaré dans le cadre de la sortie
de confinement que j'ai préparé j'ai
proposé que soit après un plan éventuel
leur confinement parce que ça se prépare
à quoi peut dire ou précise
références y avait-il des hummer
réellement un projet de re confinement
et sinon pourquoi avoir dit devant le
sénat
très bien je vais commencer par cette
question monsieur parce que je confirme
avoir tenu ces propos en effet dans la
mission qui était la mienne à l'époque
confié par edouard philippe de préparer
le déconfinement j'ai estimé nécessaire
à l'instar d'ailleurs de ce que font
tous les tous les pays qui nous
entourent de prévoir l'hypothèse où ce
déconfinement oise déconfinement
succédera une aggravation une reprise
épidémique qui on a toujours été dans le
paysage d'abord je rappelle à tout le
monde que lorsqu'on regarde l'histoire
des grandes épidémies
je pense en particulier à la grippe
espagnole d'il ya cent ans il y avait eu
deux vagues épidémiques l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
dès le départ faisait allusion à la
possibilité de plusieurs vagues
épidémiques donc dire c'est une
constante dans l'histoire des pandémies
donc je n'ai rien fait d'autre que
rappeler cette donnée est préconisé
effectivement que cette hypothèse se
produit très centré par je vous observé
d'ailleurs qu'à l'époque puisque vous y
faites allusion je m'étais exprimé
devant la commission denquête constitué
par le sénat pendant plus d'une heure et
une avait été retenu que quasiment cette
intervention où j'évoquais une
possibilité de re confirme donc oui
cette hypothèse existe elle a toujours
été un des
la gestion des épidémies et la france
comme les autres et à ses vrais parents
je vous rappelle quand on sait tous que
ce qui n'a pas était prévu c'est la
violence de la reprise ethniques qui et
quand il a été constaté dans tous les
pays d'europe c'est à dire que nous
avions l'évolution des cas c'était
plutôt linéaire et tout d'un coup ça
s'est envolée sans doute sans doute nous
disent les scientifiques sous l'effet de
facteurs climatiques sans qu'ils en
soient complètement incertaine et vous
l'avez observé tous les pays ont tous
constaté ce phénomène qui a obligé les
uns et les autres à prendre des mesures
de la nature d'ailleurs de celles que
nous avons adopté donc l'attestation
j'ai répondu comme la question allait
voir sa famille et déplacements reprend
rigoureusement me semble-t-il la même
question à laquelle j'ai répondu sur les
billets de train il y a ensuite donc une
question sur les pontons coffre commerce
et sur le nombre de cas par jour peut
être que le minsanté s'il veut venir
pour s'approcher du micro pour y
répondre puisque ce sont plutôt des
questions sanitaires et je vais répondre
moi même sur la question du conseil de
défense qui m'a été posée effective
aille que et que j'entends il me semble
que en réalité les choses sont
relativement simples
nous sommes dans une crise sanitaire
extrêmement grave sa gestion dans
l'équilibré institutionnel de notre pays
dans l'état des lois de la république et
de la séparation des pouvoirs relève du
pouvoir exécutif ce qui est inévitable
compte tenu des décisions qu'il ya mieux
de prendre parfois de la rapidité avec
laquelle doivent être prises le
parlement étant plutôt dans un rôle de
contrôle et le gouvernement compte rendu
de son action devant lui mit donc ça
c'est le premier élément le deuxième
élément c'est que me semble-t-il il à
partir pour exécuter de décider des
voies et moyens dans lesquelles ils
gèrent crise depuis le début
effectivement le président de la
république a souhaité qu' on va dire
l'instance majeur de décision soit une
instance qui existaient bien avant la
crise que vit qui s'appelle
effectivement le conseil de défense et
de sécurité nationale c'est un mois de
gouvernance qui est parfaitement
justifiée simplement ce que je veux dire
c'est que évidemment l'ensemble de
l'appareil gouvernemental prépare les
décisions du conseil de défense exécute
ensuite les décisions du conseil de
défense et donc là où je ne je comprends
pas bien la critique dont je ne la
comprends pas du tout c'est l'idée que
ce serait un pouvoir personnel avec une
opacité pas du tout 7
c'est vrai que c'est un conseil
ramassés autour du chef de l'état encore
une fois le train et gouvernement table
d administration ainsi que je salue ce
faire tant en amont qu'en aval du
conseil de défense et donc encore une
fois il n'y a rien qui me paraît
contrevenir à la séparation des pouvoirs
et au rôle normal des volutes ans de
pouvoir législatif pouvoir exécutif
monsieur les incendies quatre questions
qui relèvent pas du champ trois
questions que les chances et liqueurs
d'abord l'objectif du nombre de quatre
jours alors arrêtez ya pas un objectif
comme ministre l'a dit il ya plusieurs
objectifs l'objectif central s'est
retrouvé la maîtrise de l'épidémie
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire revenir à
un niveau de contamination par jour qui
nous permettent d'assurer le traçage de
toutes les chaînes de contamination pour
éviter qu'un nouveau les vies des mines
vos parts et donc il nous faut
déterminer quel est le bon niveau de
contamination au quotidien qui nous
permettent de faire face
est-ce que c'est 5000 que c'est dix
mille
nous organisons en assurance maladie les
agences régionales de santé pour l'été
afin de mobiliser un maximum de
professionnels pour reprendre le site
des chênes de contamination et quand
nous avons été en mesure de reprendre le
fil des chaînes de contamination et bien
alors nous serons que nous avons repris
le contrôle de les vider sur l'épidémie
en général de le deuxième indicateur
c'est la pression salutaire
c'est à dire à quel moment est-ce que
nous retrouvons avec évidemment des
animations qui seront quand même sujette
à attention mais à quel moment est que
nous arrêtons de déprogrammer des soins
nous sommes capables d'accueillir à la
cua l'image du coded et les malades qui
n'ont pas alcool il parce que ce sera le
reflet d'une baisse de la création
sanitaires et donc ça veut dire qu'il y
aura moins de gens qui ont le temps
donc moins de conséquences sanitaires
pour la population deuxième question
c'est est pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait d
évacuation sanitaire au lieu de mettre
des hôpitaux de campagne
alors d'abord l'idée des hôpitaux de
campagne ou des modifications des
hôpitaux existants
vous avez l'hôpital militaire qui a été
déployée par la ministre des armées
florence parly en polynésie française
pourquoi en polynésie française parce
que les évacuations sanitaires en
polynésie c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
auprès des pays voisins limitrophes et
donc il faut augmenter sur place les
capacités de prise en charge
hospitalière
et puis vous avez l'exemple toulousain
par exemple qui a mis en place un
système innovant pourvoir accueillir
davantage de malades jeunes conclut le
nombre d'hôpitaux que nous avons vis
qu'avec le premier ministre où on a
développé des systèmes d'urgence
d'admission d'urgence supplémentaires
que si le développement des réanimations
mais au fond deux points d'abord lorsque
vous êtes arrivé à saturation de tout le
personnel de santé disponibles dans un
hôpital
et bien vous allez mettre à contribution
davantage des hôpitaux dans lesquelles
il reste de la place disponible
plutôt que de transporter tout le
personnel de l'hôpital qui est moins
sujet à pression vers les hôpitaux les
plus sujets à caution
et ensuite il faut comprendre que ces
évacuations sanitaires elles n'ont pas
exactement le même aspect que pendant la
première vague au printemps dernier au
printemps dernier c'était des
évacuations la même souvenez vous aucune
équipe et les tgv pour pouvoir y mettre
avait des dizaines de patients pour les
accueillir en catastrophes si je puis
dire et c'est toujours heureusement bien
p les patients des hôpitaux du grand-est
vers d'autres régions
cette fois ci nous faisons des presque
des évacuations sanitaires par
anticipation de contraction sanitaire
augmente dans un territoire et qu'avec
les modélisations c'est qu'il va y avoir
davantage de patients jour après jour et
bien dans l'anticipation on transfère
certains patients transférables de ces
hôpitaux vers des endroits où il ya
davantage de places qui sont disponibles
donc c'est le tout sur les règles
sanitaires dans les petits commerces et
travaillons avec
nous avons déjà reçus à bercy les
organisations patronales et nous
continuerons de travailler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
ce qui se dessine à l'étranger notamment
là où des règles ont été mises en
vigueur je pense à l'allemagne notamment
ce qui peut y avoir ou un système de
jauge
c'est à dire un maximum de clients par
mètre carré ou plutôt un certain nombre
de mètres carrés par client ou un
système de prise de rendez vous selon
les types de commerces ou les deux et
c'est ce dont bruno le maire parlait
tout à l'heure et que nous devons
continuer de travailler dans les jours
qui viennent de manière à ce que tout
soit parfaitement prêt concertée partagé
au moment où la question se posera en
pratique
pierre une question tout à l'heure ce
qu'ils permettent sur les mariages et
les enterrements savez pendant la
première vague
il ya des familles qui n'ont pas pu
enterrer leurs morts alors comme vous
dites donc s'attendait à l inverse
c'est-à-dire avoir plus de monde aux
enterrements aussi plus de monde aux
mariages ou enterrements
je ne suis pas certain je suis même pas
du tout certains et beaucoup de familles
qui n'ont même pas pu se réunir à
quelques-uns autour de l'art des cinq
personnes pour pouvoir communier
ensemble est en tout cas rendre un
dernier hommage donc il nous a semblé au
contraire aux importants fondamentale
même d'accorder une forme de dérogation
à cette situation par ailleurs les
mariages qui sont des événements heureux
sont hélas des occasions de se réunir
partager un repas un apéritif d'ensemble
et parfois même de prolonger la soirée
et la nuit jusque très tard
je parle des invités et vous avez là us
vous avez eu là un certain nombre de
contaminations qui ont été observées
tout au long de l'été et donc été
nécessaire au contraire d'avoir des
règles extrêmement strictes
merci beaucoup donc pour revenir à une
question qui m'a été posée je vais être
très clair le 1er décembre les règles de
déplacement
l'attestation victoire ne changeront pas
par rapport à la situation actuelle et
nous allons tout faire
s'agissant des déplacements en train ou
pas pour les vacances de noël de au fur
et à mesure de l'évolution sainte-terre
préciser ça aux français dans des délais
qui leur permettront de se réunir
c'est à dire je l'espère d'ici la fin du
mois nos rangs d'accord donc à ce jour
la seule chose très pédagogique qui
pourrait changer si les conditions
sanitaires se confirme
si les protocoles sanitaires aboutissent
c'est que les commerces que nous avons
fermé pendant le confinement pourrait
rouvrir
allez je pas encore de questions
l'épidémie l'épidémie progresse
d'outre-mer particulièrement en
polynésie le centre hospitalier arrive
ces affirmations
j'aurais aussi les envisager des mesures
de durcissement dans certains
territoires d'outre-mer voire de
confinement notamment goût d'inédit
merci madame je l'entraîné dans
l'administratif pour ses nus ce cas n'a
plus fait parler d'une lueur d'espoir il
ya des médecins qui arrivent en phase
iii des essais cliniques est ce que vous
avez prévu un plan une stratégie si
michele type quelle est-elle des vaccins
arrivent donc dans leur dernière phase
en chine en allemagne au royaume uni aux
états unis en russie il ya un grand
absent c'est la france sanofi pasteur
vous avez à financer la recherche plus
d'un demi milliard d'euros comment
expliquez vous cette absence et vous
manqués des explications et et vous la
pression sur ses laboratoires français
merci je me la santé
d'abord sur le premier rejet paraît
justement par de la polynésie française
pour dire tous les efforts que nous
faisons pour leur venir en aide
pour accueillir des malades notamment
des malades en situation grave nous
travaillons avec le ministre de
l'outre-mer sébastien lecornu travail
évidemment avec l'entente de la
représentation de polynésie française
pour ajuster avec eux les mesures de
plus les plus adaptés et donc il ya des
communications communication qui sera
faite aussi prochainement sur sur ce
point particulier sur les vaccins je ne
sais pas ce que vous entendez par mettre
la pression sur la barre à quoi un
laboratoire c'est avant tout ce sont
avant tout des chercheurs qui
travaillent pour identifier un vaccin
il n'y a pas d'enfant l'occurrence de de
primauté nationale dans la capacité
qu'un laboratoire de développer un
vaccin
donc je ne crois pas qu'il faille
comparer en tout cas certainement pas
par an dont deux pays pour savoir qui
est en en avant ce qui n'est pas nous
l'avons dit à la fois que c'est une ce
serait une excellente nouvelle si un
vaccin
voyez le jour rapidement s'agissant du
laboratoire par exemple kaiser qui a
fait une annonce sur les résultats
préliminaires de son étude dite en
population générale
attention ce n'est pas terminé mais que
94 patients du côté de la population non
vaccinée qui a eu le le coc vide donc
statistiquement c'est déjà parlant c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais nous n'avons pas
encore eu accès aux données
scientifiques à toutes les dates à il
faut ensuite que la cia est coté états
unis l'agencé médicale agence européenne
du médicament puisse avoir connaissance
de toutes les analyses scientifiques
pour statuer
il déterminer si oui ou non une
autorisation de mise en marché c'est à
dire si on peut commencer une campagne
de vaccination ça c'est un point
important
d'autres laboratoires sont aussi sur le
point de faire des annonces sur
l'avancée de leurs travaux encore une
fois ce sera une excellente nouvelle que
le vainqueur soit anglais américains ou
jeu
ça restera évidemment très bonne
nouvelle pour la planète entière et face
à cela
évidemment que nous nous préparons pour
débuter le plus tôt possible une
campagne d'anna remplissant deux
conditions que le vaccin soit efficace
avec le vaccin soit sur nos corps nous
ne commençons pas une campagne vaccinale
contre le coded
si nous n'avons pas la garantie que le
vaccin est à la fois efficace et sûre
et quand je vous dis que nous préparons
c'est que par exemple s'agissant du
vaccin commercialisé par pfizer
by one tech qui est aussi une carte
européenne l'europe très content je veux
dire ah oui donc c'est européen c'est un
travail européen sur sur ce vaccin
ils nécessitent par exemple être
conservées à moins 80 degrés vous avez
bien moins 80 degrés ça court pas les
rues
nous avons d'ores et déjà acheté par
exemple c'est un exemple que je vous
donne 50 super congélateur qui permet de
stocker à moins 80 degrés des produits
sortait qui sont reliés des alarmes qui
seront entreposés dans des tentes dans
des endroits sécurisés à partir desquels
des équipes 11 déployés pour ensuite
alimenter tous ceux qui sont à mes
rétines etc c'est un chantier qui est
monumentale de charge de la vaccination
la haute autorité de santé a communiqué
en début de semaine sur le fait qu'elle
avait démarré d'ailleurs une démarche à
dire à destination des citoyens pour
renforcer la démocratie sanitaire pour
restera de déterminer quelles seraient
les conditions de vaccination
on va écrémer en parlait beaucoup de la
vaccination c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que ça veut dire que peut-être des
bazars peut-être que des vaccins sont
sur le point d'arriver et j'aurai
l'occasion de faire une
je ne sais pas à prendre une telle
conférence de presse anouk mais en tout
cas une communication plus arrêtée sur
cette question des différents vaccins et
de la façon dont 10 avant d'envisager
les choses mais
évidemment nous y préparons merci
beaucoup d'arbres et messieurs et donc à
très bientôt
lors des votes